dass maze
ja sechs diamanten ok fall gerne
bestimmten so hilger damit einfach nur
noch einmal kurz mal gemacht
wie kommst du angst weil ich okay kommt
ständig hinkommt schnell wieder zurück
zur küste
ich bin jetzt da bin jetzt da glaube ich
schon ja hier so ok ok schmeißt ihr die
puschen immerhin haben wir beide night
vision stellt diamanten
ich muss gleich zwei schwerter ok geil
alter kinder aber auch in
holzverbrennung 1 und schärfe 22
was machen wir hier wirklich rein tun
nein nicht in die kiste ist auf jeden
fall mit nicht dass hier noch welche
hinkommt jeder nimmt einen diamanten von
uns ja ja aber wofür er besser als wenn
einer stirbt dann hat der einen
jagdschein zu finden jeder einheit dann
kann er nichts anfangen damit wir jetzt
was hast du erstens hass und schwert ich
habe einen diamanten schwerte holk mit
schärfe 2 und martin hielt pastor
rüstung komplett und hose verzauberten
feuerschutz ok ich hab' noch lahmer hast
du fackeln nebenbei wackeln 3
hast du was zu essen ja ich hab noch
einen porsche noch feeling okay dann
gucken wir noch kurz in die kiste ob da
etwas ist ich würde sagen dass wir
wertvolle sachen einfach mal mitnehmen
nein wir können auch die alles zu bauen
das finden jedoch nicht das okay stimmt
eben hier die erde raus machen hier
komplett zu also meine wir wissen wo es
ist die anderen werden hier nicht
zurechtkommen leiste
das ist nur mit tnt hast du irgendein
ding flint ich habe fackeln gemacht mit
dienstag sind bräuchten wir vielleicht
für das tnt
wir haben hier nicht flint habe ich ja
okay dann macht dann nimmt waters tnt
und dann gelaufen zu sein
hast du zwei eisen hier jeder kriegt
einen flint und zwei tnt hat nämlich
zwei fans sagt einem wo sind die tnt
dinge habe ich dazu geworfen auch hier
habe ich sie bekommen ja sogar kriegst
du nämlich dass und das beim warm dann
hat jeder nämlich hier genug
es kommt so das kommt es so wir können
uns jetzt mal richtig zu nehmen ja ich
habe schon mal raus das heißt jemand der
da muss wirklich auf den block genau
hier die kisten finden
wir wissen ja wusste gesagt okay läuft
wir hätten noch viel stone backen müssen
sowie zeit muss sein alter ich glaube
wir haben diamant schwert und komplette
rüstung wir werden das schaffen glaube
ich wäre nicht die alles schlecht rede
sein
attacke wir gehen auf jeden fall
zusammen das ok nicht sprinten einfach
normal laufen nicht brennt nicht
sprinten
wie viel leistung hast du ich habe alles
bis auf alle alles voll bis auf
zweieinhalb du hast auch noch
verzögerungen bei den diamant werde ich
glaube uns wird keiner angreifen du hast
diamant schwert weg gehen das voller das
holz wird
ich habe auch das ipad in der hand an
kombinationen sind und dann wir ba
angemahnt und fackeln oder so eine hand
und dann das so ganz schnell auf der
matte blind in die hand
wildfeuer ausgestellt
das waren wir nicht das wollen wir nicht
warten das einfach mal alles anzünden
da waren wir wir kommen alter ich will
mal so ein großer baum anzünden wo bist
du gerade jetzt ins toggenburg wo bist
du herr mein gott wo bist du
ich bin jetzt weitergelaufen richtung
spork 11,28 alter krass wo wir das nicht
junge ball brennt sondern dieses auch
noch größerem ich sehe dich bleibt
einfach stehen ich seit ich hier bin ich
hier der ist ja vielleicht haben sie
irgendwelche auf bäume gebaut das kann
ja auch sein
beim verschwendet nicht das feuerzeug so
heftig also ich glaube aber schon dass
die anderen links da gefunden haben
jemanden
gut dass wir am ende noch welche
gefunden habe als mein glück ist ihm
schon wieder denn hier oben auf dem berg
wo bist du auch da unten okay sie kommen
einfach hoch ja ich habe mich ein
bisschen um mit opti fallen hier sowohl
bisschen rum besuchen
rang eins oben
ich kann die minimap einstellen dass
sehen keinen
keiner draußen alles los ist ja wir sind
oben ok sonnig
wenn man den baum angezündet wird mit
der inspur das skelett orchesters
entweder bist du arthas skelettes erst
mal relativ egal
das tun wird ist kohlevorkommen hier wo
bist du ja das ist egal wen ich hatte
wofür ein alter wo bist du denn wo bist
du vorne rein gegangen
wtf bestand ist da war links direkt zum
schluss ohne kleine es gab moskito
schwamm ich bin ich doch so dass in
kryta wenn wir doch in kryta haben jetzt
und der nähe das musst du dir zunächst
weil wir brauchen dingsda dienten dem
brauch stammt ist nur aufgefallen machen
können warum die hacker machen müssen
meine schwester fragt mich gerade ob ich
was von max will ja immer was ganz kurz
beschützen
na gut dann schreibe ich mal ganz kurz
ich dann ein paar bürger
ich will ein
und ein spielzeug
muss
dass maze das haus warte dass man dazu
diesem pilz links gehen siehst du das ja
da warst du da warst du schon mal gucken
was findet neuerdings immer nacht wissen
verliert dann fängt es an zu blinken
zoom warnsignal
das war bei mir nämlich gerade jetzt und
komische schaaf wieder auf den tod
mein pass auf gleich ist ein diamant
schnell kaputt ich glaube so schnell
geht das nicht
nein das ist ein typ ein typ das sind
typen wirklich drauf gehen was drauf
gehen kommen jetzt action jetzt
angelaufen da hinten ist was ist was da
gerade etwas essen
wenn die menschen anpacken bei uns hätte
es wohl wusste hingelaufen links links
links rum läuft du four ich sehe hier
gerade gar nichts weiter habe ich noch
nicht gesehen ersten jahr lang gelaufen
nirgendwo unsichtbaren denn diamant in
hand das wäre es wenn das lächeln
sichtbar hier dann kommt klar alter mann
wo is' sehr lange laufen fakt irgendwo
hier werde ich bestimmt irgendwo eine
hülle gepackt und schmid lassen die
richtung gehen
schaue mich ein bisschen um
springt mir oder nochmal sprinten wir
haben so viel essen
wir müssen den typen die kriegen alle
welche töten ich glaube jetzt ein
bisschen rum von wegen von hinten da ist
einer weitern ab da läuft da ja ist
blackrock ist das ab was okay ab geht's
ja ich sehe dich ich hoffe ich bin hier
ja live besser ist nach links
abgedriftet ja wir haben bessere rüstung
reisen rüstung aber ich glaub die haben
kein diamant wird einfach drauf gehen
drauf gehen
kom kom kom kom kom igen eisens schwert
lauf lassen das grab von moskitos von
komm schon
ich habe ihn gleich ja ich bin auch
hinter dir überlebens plex so die duh
direkt unter dem herrlich geht so bei
den berg vielleicht auf dann ist links
rum hat mich auf den offenen wirtschaft
daher der ist im wasser hier kommen ja
den haben wir weg geflachst keller
was haben wir viele bekommen
irgendwelche sachen eine schöne rösti so
gefällt mir das geil meinte gar nichts
gehabt hast du dich von ihm bekommt ja
nun misst gehabt alter ich hab noch
nicht mal schaden von ihm bekommen
ihr hattet ja nur mist über richtig
arrogant wo bist du bist du okay was man
hier einfach so kurz stellen was hat das
alles mit eisen schwerte hatte keine
gallen sachen er hätte gar nix geiles
jeder hatte er hat glück gehabt oder
nicht ja aber wenn man rüstung 7 lapis
lazuli mit zehn pfeile das war's und
holz spitzhacken das heißt wir sind
eigentlich schon relativ gut dabei zu
straffe haut sie den song in flammen
auch vor kritik natürlich meine ich habe
mir inventar auch so sortiert wird
theoretisch vor welchen weg laufen die
verzauberte sachen dann plötzlich ganz
schnell den lover einmal hinter uns und
pagani tnt dahin
so ist es brauch weiter sind einfach
weiter schnitzel alles an leiter gs
irgendwas fliegendes okay so sieht es
auch sehr gut aus so schöne ecke aber
das verstehen geblieben ist im wasser
lässt sich da so ein kitzeln lassen
er ist einfach still dachte wirklich der
klingt hat er das diamant wird nicht
gesehen
conti selbst jetzt überall unsere bahnen
jetzt einfach alles an hase tod alle
gleich ist man voll kaputt ist immer
noch ein paar sachen 50 prozent also ja
dann lass es lieber dass man dies wie
ein hase wo bist du wir dürfen uns auf
keinen fall verlieren
du willst du bist du ja okay ich sehe
dich ich seh dich ich bin bei dir jedoch
nicht herr
ich bin bei diesem steinkreis hier
darauf ist angezündet das genau da wo
jörg lieg ich komme da hin
d d d d d d d kostet ab und ich denke
ich ich sehe dass wir angegriffen wie
ein baum nur das erinnert mich an das
zuger von ganz da wo bist du jetzt schon
wieder richtig auch wieder nicht gerade
ausgelaufen
mal zurück müssen wirklich zusammen
laufen
alles brennt wird ja wohl abbildung 1 an
die wand da war glaube ich jemand ja
nicht sprinten erst mal hatte ich nehme
das mal hier ins häuschen
hier ist kaputt
standard ab
und schon wieder ein fragt okay ist dann
bleibt kurz am leben war ja fast dieser
fortschritt komisch manchmal gibt aber
auch außen manchmal nicht was geht jetzt
schnell was machen muss komm schon
stadland spiel mitspielt mag nicht wenn
es lädt sich das jetzt gleich da kommt
noch nicht fest aber egal ich mich
einfach hin jetzt da war ich bin noch
nicht da jetzt bin ich wieder da und
problems tue ich sehe ich noch nicht ich
sehe ich auch nicht da bist du ja ok
kommen lasse einfach hierhin hier brennt
mir ein bisschen zu viel
dann zieht man jemandem schuld auch und
guck mal alles brennt ab
der baum da ganz hinten er bringt auch
schon heraus zwei leidlich klingen
aneinander nein da dürfen wenn ich nen
er hinlaufen glaube ich nein der ist da
oben irgendwo im baum glaube ich auch im
internet hoch klettern ich wette mit
oder auch einfach abfackeln kann ich
hier ist er gewesen
könnt ihr nochmal kurz ja mal
reinschauen okay ich bin ja von der
seite eingegangen als schön die augen
offen nach spielern weil ich glaub hier
könnten viele sein
hier ist wieder an blumen sich versucht
mal ihr könnt ihr auch einfach mal kurz
daraus ich hab doch die braune wolle und
ganz viele steine das heißt wir könnten
denen einfach theoretisch kommen wieder
rauskommen daraus machen wir könnten ja
mal theoretisch einzigen hätte ich ja
mal in ihrer lust drauf sonst ist das
wasser nämlich am nächsten nicht weg ok
schade und er aber das ist egal
ich hab mich letzten mal auf der anderen
seite reingegangen deswegen lass uns mal
hier ein graben warte ich mal ganz kurz
ein paar unnötige sachen rein
die ich alle nicht mehr brauche ich komm
raus komm raus komm raus
pass auf
leider alter wir kriegen nicht mal was
das buch habe ich tot
es war ein buch mob alter bub
ich würde sagen wir können ich hab
einfach eingehen wenn jetzt schon drin
sind erst kürzlich ist die kiste im wald
ganz ruhig war
wir können ja vielleicht hochgehen ich
bin ja ein detail hier weil ich auch
schnee sonne immer schlägt mich leider
das ist das buch von hobart
deshalb stellen ob es das drop bücher
ich glaub ich spinne raus kommt bei uns
nicht dass ihr doch sterben europa chef
forster hinweis hin
ich bin komplett verlangsamt ja hier ist
der belag war irgendwie ja allerdings
dadurch einen weiteren brand gesetzt ja
das ist ein kleines problem wir können
hier reingehen fahrzeug ich bin hinter
die räder da bin ich genauer eingegangen
das ist doch schon ein gang gehe habe
ich gemacht luca war ich doch schon
jawala so ja ich will trotzdem bin ich
nicht
deswegen weiß ich gerade nicht ob wir
hochgehen sollten könnte probieren ich
habe angst dass jeder der mal eine
steife hier spielt so viel ab nach unten
nach dem motto 'der so oben ja komm wir
gehen einfach wie gehen wir haben sogar
ihre sachen
ich habe eine verzauberung ich bin ganz
langsam verzauberung netzwerk ist es weg
kommen hätten das wecken von da alter so
zugebaut warte warte hat mich müssen
jetzt irgendwie suchen wir stellen jetzt
schon angst dass wir ihnen die stadt
jetzt brennt's irgendwo kommt jetzt
schon einfach alles ab irgendwo wo ist
denn schon wieder wo bist du
folge einfach dem feuer ist moritz wurde
ist jetzt wieder dahin zurück ich bin
direkt neben dem indirekt er sich da
schon die branche hier lang gehen alles
da alter ich glaub jetzt die einzigen
beiden so wirklich ex chef bei den
anderen sind allerdings noch unter der
erde mit diamanten bestimmt arsch selten
aber das mit lustige war die diamanten
waren in einer höhle ich musste die
nicht wendung gaben
wie schwer so ein brunnen restlos herein
warte ich die kokosnuss ist schaue noch
mal das bessere augen als ich das ist
ich hätte eigentlich bock das mal so im
real zu spielen weil das ist eigentlich
so wichtiges rpg teil